[Music]
national geographic and mazda started
assignment inspiration
three quests to challenge photographers
to test their ability to tell a
compelling visual story and to capture
inspiring imagery
beth nina sam congratulations to each of
you
truly a once in a lifetime opportunity
to compete for a chance to photograph
for national geographic travel
just to be able to represent both
national geographic and mazda
i feel like i've been validated so i'm
bringing my a game it's a big
opportunity
that lays ahead i think i'm one step
closer to being a nacho photographer
it would be wonderful to win because
what that means
is that someone saw the potential in me
this
quest is about capturing images that
define what it means to uplift humanity
this for me really is about the
emotional connection that you make
between the people that you photograph
and the way that you convey those
emotions what's inspiring you to click
that shutter
the challenge is to capture that emotion
and convey it through your photographs
so we can be inspired as well
you will have only three hours to
photograph your subjects it's gonna be
tough
and in the end you're gonna bring back
your five best images from each place
and we're providing each of you with a
mazda cx-30 which we hope will inspire
you
to inspire us to inspire everyone else
who sees your amazing photos
when i meet a young photographer who
wants to do what i've been lucky enough
to do i can't help but want to be a part
of that
and help welcome them into this amazing
life that i feel i've been lucky to live
at mazda we craft our cars to inspire
our drivers every interaction with the
mazda brand we hope to uplift
it's what inspired assignment
inspiration when i was thinking about
things that are uplifting i thought back
to when i started volunteering at a
local nursing home
as a high school student it left a
lasting impression on me
changing the course of my life that's
how i decided to go into medicine
we're at a memory care home to capture
some nice moments with kids for peace
students that are working on activities
with the residents here
here we go kids for peace
they feel that through acts of kindness
that can spread peace
that connection between a younger person
who doesn't know that much about life
yet but filled with so much curiosity
and someone who has lived with this
wonderful perspective
getting those fresh interactions that's
when it's the most genuine i need to be
ready
the name of the game is flexibility
keeping my eyes open
some of it's like hard with angles i
want to be down more on their level
and i'll go to take a shot but then an
arm comes in
so that has been a challenge but it's
fun
to push yourself
[Music]
for me being outdoors in nature it's
like a reset button
it kind of puts me at peace so for
uplifted i'm choosing to focus on
human and animal interaction as it
pertains to conservation
hey sam welcome hey how are y'all good
to meet you good to meet you
hi i'm denise welcome to sky falconry
yeah thank you so much i chose
sky falconry ranch a place where people
can come and
interact with birds of prey in a
respectful and
natural sort of way the emotional aspect
of the uplifted challenge is
incredibly captivating if you can
capture how we feel
every day then i think you're in the
right place she could jump off at any
second
and there she goes but i'm worried about
what that's going to look like
especially having an entire crew around
me while i'm doing photography
if i'm connected then people are going
to see that
they're going to feel that connection
and hopefully be inspired by my work
a national geographic photographer needs
to be curious curious about the world
compassionate when you're intimately
invested you tell stories that are
richer and deeper
it comes from the heart we are at ride
on horse therapy center
what they do here is work with special
needs children and teach them
horseback riding motor skills and how to
connect with animals
i have two children that have special
needs so for me to be able to come out
here today and document this
is a really incredible experience and
i'm just in heaven
one two three yeah so what was really
beautiful is just that these kids get to
come out here and
just get to be kids for a moment time is
flying by because i'm having a great
time and there's all this action and
there's just never
a dull moment i'm trying to capture them
going around and it's a little bit
challenging it's interesting she's
riding backwards
not quite sure where i should position
myself when i think i haven't figured
out which way they're gonna go
the horses are like
the x factor in photography is often
about that moment
that reveals how humans have the power
to uplift and be uplifted
[Music]
children are inherently inspirational to
me that energy
that children bring can be really
healing
[Music]
i mean it just fills your heart being
able to witness
connections that people are making it's
it's pretty sweet
whoa shag tea she is
in massive hunting mode right now
she sneezed i didn't know birds could
sneeze yeah
lots of action with these animals so
really trying to capture their movements
they're really unpredictable
if you don't have that good working
relationship it's hasta la vista bud
it's such a rare opportunity to interact
with birds of prey
and it is such a gift when they actually
choose to come to you and especially
when they choose to come
to our guests we at sky falconry hold
a special permit that allowed
non-licensed falconers the opportunity
of flying one of our birds at prey you
know i get that sort of adrenaline rush
that you get when you know that
something's happening and it's a
fleeting moment
beautiful as this woman holds
[ __ ] for the first time her face lights
up
this is the moment that i've been
looking for throughout the shoot
it's not something i can ask her to
recreate
that look on their face the sheer joy
they got
for me the definition of uplifting
[Music]
i love it my kids could do something
like this
all these volunteers out here that's
amazing i really need to watch all the
different things that they do with the
different kids they really have it
tailored to their needs so i want to be
far enough back so that
the children and horses reactions are
natural but i do want to make sure that
i'm able to capture
those uplifting moments and not miss a
thing
such a great smile oh my goodness we
were giving them so much smile and love
when they were walking around
there were so many different moments of
connection
you know i don't know if i was snapping
the photos fast enough to really convey
that in the photos
but i felt uplifted the whole entire
time how'd it go
i think it went well yeah it definitely
gives me all the feels
really excited about the shots i got and
what i got to witness today i put so
much of myself into these photos
but i don't ultimately have control what
someone's going to take away from it and
that's part of the vulnerability of any
art form
i'm excited to go home and see what i
got i know i'm gonna have my work cut
out for me
picking five favorites is gonna be a
really hard task
just to watch these children get an
experience you know you'll come out
and do this thing that they might not
otherwise get to do
to just be kids i could just see how
happy they were
and how much it meant to them it was
really
powerful and heartwarming